i
[Música]
el corre y está andrés zarautz lidera la
votación en ecuador tras las elecciones
presidenciales sin embargo irá a una
segunda vuelta del centroderechista
guillermo lasso y el indígena medio
ambientalista ya q pérez se disputa en
la segunda posición para competir con
araus en la contienda del 11 de abril
tenemos reporte de séquito
en medio de protestas y el descontento
en las calles el presidente de
activision el mois reafirmó que no
abandonara el poder como exige la
oposición y el poder judicial y denunció
un intento de golpe de estado ayer
cuando se culminaba su mandato según la
oposición pero para mover su gobierno
termina en un año
ya son 18 los fallecidos en india y más
de 200 desaparecidos tras la avalancha
de agua y lodo ocurrida a causa de la
ruptura de un glaciar en el norte de ese
país entretanto continúan a contrarreloj
las labores de rescate el primer
ministro indio narendra modi anunció
ayudas económicas para las familias de
las víctimas
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 blanco como siempre un
gusto saludarlos comenzamos en ecuador
que vivió ayer su primera vuelta en las
elecciones presidenciales con 16
candidatos a ser jefes de estado según
el conteo rápido emitido por el consejo
nacional electoral andrés zarautz
el candidato de izquierda respaldado por
el ex presidente rafael correa tiene
hasta el momento 30 y 1.5 por ciento de
los votos tiene un embate técnico está
por definirse el contendiente en la
segunda vuelta de las presidenciales
entre el líder indígena ya q pérez con
el 20.0 4% y el ex banquero de
centroderecha guillermo lasso con el 19
puntos 97 por ciento de los votos hasta
ahora más del 95 por ciento escrutado
pero veamos el siguiente informe
mientras se publicaban las encuestas de
boca de urna la celebración ya estaba en
su auge en quitó para el economista de
izquierda andrés árabes la contundente
victoria estaba a la vista está no hay
ninguna duda estamos en el primer lugar
hemos recibido una votación abrumadora
de distintas partes de nuestra patria el
favorito de 36 años representa la unión
por la esperanza una coalición de
partidos de izquierda su mentor es el ex
presidente rafael correa que sigue
teniendo influencia en ecuador a pesar
de vivir en el exilio mientras se va de
cargos por corrupción en su país la
promesa del regreso de un camino
socialista ha impulsado la campaña de
árabes así como sus promesas de ayudar a
millones de familias mientras grava con
impuestos especiales a los más ricos
pero mientras sara usa asegura su lugar
en la segunda vuelta en la madrugada de
este lunes la carrera por el segundo
puesto seguía muy apretada para
definirse la batalla está entre el ex
banquero de derecha guillermo lasso y el
activista por los derechos indígenas ya
q pérez ambos claman la victoria
ponen en segunda vuelta
[Aplausos]
así nosotros no ganemos pues nosotros
respetaremos pero en este caso nosotros
ganamos de entramos a la segunda vuelta
eso es irreversible con un margen tan
apretado cualquier candidato podría
pedir un recuento manual y determinar
quién enfrentará araús en la segunda
vuelta del 11 de abril para ganar
contundentemente un candidato necesitará
el 50% de los votos o al menos un 40%
con un margen de 10 puntos sobre su
oponente más cercano
nos acompaña el séquito nuestro
corresponsal gustavo ortega ha gustado
muy buenos días andrés araus apadrinado
político del ex presidente rafael correa
obtuvo ayer la victoria en esta primera
vuelta y avanza hace la segunda que se
va a realizar el 11 de abril qué
consecuencias políticas se atraería el
regreso de socialismo ecuador
sí muy buenos días para ti a pesar de
que rafael correa está inhabilitado
hasta el año 2028 a pesar de que vive en
bélgica ha sido el contundente
protagonista de las elecciones en
ecuador qué consecuencias podría tener
bueno en principio la vuelta al
socialismo en ecuador significa también
la revisión de los acuerdos con el fondo
monetario internacionales significa
también la reversión de la ley
humanitaria aplicada por el presidente
lenin moreno y significa también la
aplicación del modelo correísta en este
país las consecuencias son las que ya se
están viendo inclusive por los distintos
actores y que son adversos corregimos se
ha dicho ya que todos irán a una segunda
vuelta para apoyar y evitar así que
andrés ahora usted haga con la
presidencia de realizarse la segunda
vuelta el 11 de abril inclusive llama la
atención como los factores que
rechazaron a los movimientos indígenas e
inclusive indicaban que los movimientos
indígenas debían irse al páramo durante
las protestas de octubre de 2019 ahora
inclusive están diciendo que apostarían
por un apoyo contundente a este
y es que el apoyo a para evitar la
vuelta al correísmo es la tónica en este
momento de igual forma también ya q
pérez verlo protestando sobre apoyar lo
que según él indica un fraude por lo que
es un conteo que está muy ajustado en
los resultados de consejo nacional
electoral también en la tónica que está
sucediendo en el ecuador así ha gustado
y es que como lo veíamos también aún no
se sabe quién será el otro candidato que
ir a segunda vuelta y un empate técnico
entre el activista ambiental ya q pérez
y el ex banquero conservador guillermo
lasso le pregunto cómo va el conteo
hasta ahora son un consejo nacional
electoral y también cuánto se ha
procesado hasta el momento
bueno hasta el momento el consejo
nacional electoral está procesando un
aproximado del 97 por ciento según se
refleja a esta hora en su portal web
a pesar que existe un 97 por ciento de
las actas escrutadas se ha dicho que
existe un empate técnico la diferencia
entre la cv pérez y el banquero
guillermo lasso dan cuenta de que existe
un margen muy cercano en cuanto a la
diferencia de los resultados pero ya q
pérez reclama que él es el candidato que
irá en segunda vuelta por su parte
pudimos ver ayer en las inmediaciones
del consejo nacional electoral en el
área de totalización donde él reclama en
este momento que existe un fraude y sus
partidarios reclaman un pronunciamiento
de lo más pronto de consejo nacional
electoral gustado gracias por su reporte
estaremos muy pendientes entonces lo que
ocurre en ecuador el presidente de ti y
yo en el mois denunció un intento de
golpe de estado el domingo 7 de febrero
23 personas fueron arrestadas entre los
cuales se encuentra un juez de la mayor
instancia judicial del país y es que la
oposición y amplios sectores de la
sociedad civil aseguran que moix
a dejar su cargo el día de ayer mientras
que el presidente argumenta que todavía
le queda un año de mandato esta disputa
se trasladó a las calles donde
centenares de personas vieron la
renuncia el mandatario más romeros a la
nos tiene todos los detalles
vuelven las protestas a las calles de
puerto príncipe y de nuevo es para pedir
la renuncia del presidente joven el mois
según la oposición y gran parte de la
sociedad civil debía dejar el cargo este
7 de febrero con eso desde hoy ya no
reconocemos a yo en el móvil en el
palacio nacional porque su mandato
terminó
la iglesia haitiana y el poder judicial
también consideran que debe renunciar
sin embargo a raíz de una interpretación
distinta de la constitución móvil
asegura que le queda un año en el poder
y tiene el apoyo de washington y de la
organización de estados americanos
además 23 personas fueron detenidas el
domingo acusadas de planear un golpe de
estado entre los cuales se encuentra un
juez de la corte suprema y una alto
cargo de la policía
cote que planificación porque planeaban
arrestar al presidente obama
nacional y planeaban invadir el palacio
para instalar un presidente provisional
que ya tenía su discurso preparado ella
de hecho la oposición llevaba semanas
hablando de su intención de hacer una
transición de poder con un presidente
interino que sustituyera a moix sin
embargo parece que por ahora el
presidente seguirá en el cargo a pesar
de que las calles de la oposición piden
su renuncia desde hace años
bajo su mandato haití ha atravesado
fuertes crisis de seguridad un
incremento de secuestros graves
problemas de suministro energético y
altos índices de corrupción
en india las autoridades continúan las
labores de rescate y elevaron a 18 la
cifra de muertos y más de 200 la
desaparecidos por la avalancha ocurrida
luego de la rotura de un glaciar en el
norte de ese país a 500 kilómetros de
nueva delhi la capital el desastre tuvo
lugar el domingo por la mañana en la
cordillera del himalaya y gran parte de
las labores de rescate se están
centrando en la búsqueda de los
trabajadores de dos centrales
hidroeléctricas en construcción
afectadas por esta avalancha
este túnel que es enorme se ha abierto
entre 70 a 80 metros entre una gran
cantidad de escombros por lo que hay un
bloqueo completo las dos máquinas
excavadoras están entrando para
despejarlo el túnel tiene 180 metros de
largo y hay otro pasadizo de desagüe
donde desde ayer quedaron atrapados
entre 30 y 40 trabajadores aquí nos
estamos tratando de rescatar fase un
calce común con ical de kph y de esta
manera llegamos al final del informativo
en france 24 continúen con nosotros para
más actualizaciones de noticias hasta
pronto
[Música]
realmente